H의 거듭제곱이 초기 상태에 점점 더 많이 적용되면서요. 마치 시간 진화를 통해 Krylov 부분 공간을
만들 수 있을 것 같아요. 거의 맞아요. 주의할 점은
실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 시간 진화를 실현하는 방법이에요. Hamiltonian의 항들 중 많은 것들이 서로 교환하지 않아요.
그래서 e의 마이너스 i z 같은 단순한 지수 연산자들은 단순한
circuit에 대응하지만, 일반적인 Hamiltonian은 그렇지 않아요. 비가환 항들을 포함하기 때문에
숫자처럼 지수 함수를 단순한 것들의 곱으로 분해할 수가 없어요. 그래서
간단하지 않지만, 양자 컴퓨팅에서 잘 연구된 과정이에요. 양자 컴퓨터에서 시간 진화는
trotterization이라는 과정을 통해 수행하는데, 그 자체로도 풍부한 주제예요. 하지만 매우 높은 수준에서,
시간 진화를 작은 M개의 단계로 나눔으로써 항들의 비가환성 효과를 제한해요.
고전적인 맥락에서 H의 거듭제곱을 직접 사용해서 생성한 차수 r의 Krylov 부분 공간을
power Krylov 부분 공간 kpr이라고 부를게요.
이제 iht의 지수 함수로 주어지는 유니터리 시간 진화 연산자 u를 사용해서 유사한 공간을 생성해요.
이걸 unitary Krylov 공간 kur이라고 부를게요.
고전적으로 사용하는 power Krylov 부분 공간 kpr은 h가 유니터리 연산자가 아니기 때문에
양자 컴퓨터에서 직접 생성할 수 없어요. unitary Krylov 부분 공간을 사용하면
power Krylov 부분 공간과 유사한 수렴 보장을 줄 수 있다는 게 밝혀져 있어요.
구체적으로, 초기 상태 V가 진정한 바닥 상태와 지수적으로 소멸하지 않는 겹침을 가지고
있는 한, 그리고 고유 상태들 사이에 충분한 간격이 있는 한 바닥 상태 오차가 효율적으로 수렴해요.
여기서 u의 거듭제곱은 서로 다른 시간 단계가 돼요. u의 k번째 거듭제곱은
k * dt만큼 앞으로 나아가는 거예요.
총 시간 kdt만큼 시간 진화된 부분 공간의 원소를 s sub k로 표시할 수 있어요. Hamiltonian
H를 unitary Krylov 부분 공간 kur에 투영할 수 있어요. 다시 말해,
kur basis에서 h의 각 행렬 원소를 계산해요. 이
투영 행렬을 H tilde라고 부를게요. H tilde의 행렬 원소들은 양자 컴퓨터를 사용해서
추정할 수 있는 이러한 기댓값들로 주어져요.
H는 서로 다른 qubit들에 대한 Pauli 연산자들의 합으로 쓸 수 있고, 모든 Pauli 연산자를
동시에 측정할 수는 없다는 걸 기억해요. Pauli 항들을 교환하는 항들의 그룹으로 분류하고 한꺼번에 측정할 수 있어요.
하지만 모든 항을 다루려면 그런 그룹이 많이 필요할 수 있어요. 항들을 분류할 수 있는 교환 그룹의 수
ngcp가 중요해져요. 차원 r의 unitary Krylov 부분 공간을 사용하면
결과 행렬은 r * r 차원이 돼요. r이 n보다 훨씬 작으면
유용한 진전을 이룬 거고, 보통 r은 100보다 훨씬 작아서 고전 컴퓨터에서
쉽게 대각화할 수 있어요. 하지만 s n과 s m은 일반적으로 직교하지 않는다는 걸 기억해요.
비직교 basis에서 행렬을 대각화하는 것이 때로는 가능해요. 하지만 수치적, 물리적 이유로
먼저 직교 basis로 바꾸는 게 좋아요. 그래서 Gram 행렬 s를 사용해서 일반화된 고유값 문제를 풀어요.
Gram 행렬의 mn 원소는 s m과 cn의 내적으로 주어져요.
H tilde와 S의 원소는 모두 Hadamard 테스트를 사용해서 계산해요.
그러면 일반화된 고유값 문제는 이렇게 돼요.
위에서 언급했듯이, unitary Krylov 부분 공간의 차원 R은 초기
행렬 차원 N보다 지수적으로 작아요. 그래서 이 값 문제는 고전적으로 쉽게 풀 수 있어요.
정리하면, 기준 상태에서 시작해서 서로 다른 시간 동안 진화시켜 unitary
Krylov 부분 공간을 생성해요. Hamiltonian을 그 부분 공간에 투영하고 부분 공간
벡터들의 겹침도 추정해요. 마지막으로, 더 낮은 차원의 일반화된 값 문제를 고전적으로 풀어요. Krylov 기법을
고전적으로와 양자역학적으로 사용할 때 계산 비용을 결정하는 요소를 비교해봐요. 이미
고전 버전에 대해 간략히 설명했고, 모든 단계에서 고전적, 양자적 접근 간에 완벽한 유사점이 있는 건 아니에요. 하지만 이 표에 고려할
여러 단계의 스케일링이 정리되어 있어요. Hamiltonian은 일반적으로 동시에 측정할 수 없는 항들을 가지고 있다는 걸 기억해요. 왜냐하면
교환하지 않기 때문이에요. Hamiltonian의 항들을 동시에 측정할 수 있는 교환 Pauli 연산자 그룹으로 분류하고, 교환하지 않는 모든 항을 처리하려면 많은
그룹이 필요할 수 있어요. 양자 컴퓨터에서 H tilde를 구축하려면
Hamiltonian에서 교환 Pauli 문자열의 각 그룹에 대해 별도의 측정이 필요해요. 그리고 각각 많은 shots가 필요해요. 이걸 R
제곱개의 서로 다른 행렬 원소에 대해 해야 하는데, 서로 다른 시간 진화 인수의 R 제곱 조합에 해당해요.
이를 줄이는 방법도 있어요. 하지만 이 대략적인 계산에서 필요한 시간은 대략
shots 수 곱하기 교환 Pauli 항 그룹의 수 곱하기 r 제곱에 비례해요.
S의 원소를 추정해야 하는데, 이건 shots 수에 비례해서 증가해요.
r 세제곱에 비례해요. Hamiltonian의 교환 Pauli 그룹의 수가 비교적 적은 경우에 quantum Krylov 대각화가 유용할 수 있어요.
Hamiltonian에서요.
이 스케일링 의존성은 Krylov 방법이 유용한 응용 분야와 그렇지 않을 응용 분야를 시사해요.
일부 Hamiltonian은 qubit에 매핑될 때 많은 비가환 Pauli 문자열을 포함하는 높은 복잡도를 가져요.
소수의 교환 그룹으로 쉽게 분류할 수 없는 경우죠.
이건 양자 화학 문제에서 자주 나타나요. 예를 들어, 이 복잡도는 근접
양자 컴퓨터에 두 가지 주요 과제를 제기해요. 첫째, H tilde의 각 원소를 추정하는 것이 항의 수가
많아서 계산적으로 비싸져요. 둘째, 필요한 Trotter circuit이 지나치게 깊어져요. 이 두 가지 문제는
양자 컴퓨터가 오류 허용에 도달하면 덜 문제가 되겠지만, 근접 기간에는 고려해야 해요. 더 단순한 매핑을 가진 시스템도